au vélodrome nationale les épreuves
sportives pourrait se vivre différemment
le site saint quentinois avaient
expérimenté la 5g
c'est pour le vélodrome mais c'est ce
n'est pas dédié exclusivement puisque ya
déjà des entreprises qui ont des projets
adjacent autour du vélodrome qui vont
pouvoir tester par exemple des éléments
de sécurité
je pense airbus je pense à d'autres
entreprises
l'agglomération à porter une candidature
en partenariat avec airbus nokia france
télévisions et qualcomm une société
américaine de technologies mobiles
on pourrait avoir en temps direct 1
sur son téléphone des exemples l'avatar
des l'avatar des cyclistes avec leurs
noms leurs caractéristiques tout leur
toutes leurs données instantanées qui
soit sur son téléphone en même temps que
le téléspectateur pourrez regarder la
course
un baby x 10 un temps de latence divisé
par dix on cite français ont été
sélectionnés suite à l'appel de l'arcep
le régulateur des télécoms français pour
le moment on n'a pas testé et donc il
faut tout construire il faut construire
à la fois des techno mais il faut
construire aussi les modèles d'affaires
qu'on s'assure et qu'économiquement les
intuitions sont justes et pour faire ça
il faut un bac à sable qu'ils soient
protégés ouvert où tout le monde peut
avoir accès et qui permettent de tester
pendant trois ans les projets
expérimenteront la bande de fréquence 26
giga hertz une première en france en
point de mire pour le vélodrome les jo
de 2024